in january 2008 unbeknownst to the world
something shady was happening off the
southern coast of sri lanka
construction was beginning on a shiny
new 4 000 acre port in the tiny town of
hambantota
85 of the 361 million dollar price tag
was paid for with chinese loans
but this on its own was no cause for
concern china's xm bank funds thousands
of projects around the world
what was strange was the location
positioned between the suez canal and
strait of malacca tens of thousands of
ships passed by each year on their way
between europe and asia one of the
busiest transcontinental routes
yet sri lanka with a population of 21
million already had a profitable
functioning port just 100 miles
northwest in colombo
the world's 25th busiest in fact
so why then build a second so close in
such a small town and at such great
expense
sure enough this skepticism would soon
be vindicated
in 2012
3667 ships birthed at the neighboring
port of colombo
two years had passed then since the
opening of hambantota yet it attracted
just 34.
by 2016 the project had lost 230 million
dollars according to its own ministry of
finance
and there's more
in addition to the seaport an equally
pristine and equally empty airport was
built nearby
the last remaining airline pulled out in
2018 due to insufficient demand
its long runway and modern terminal may
now be used for long-term parking
so if not profit what motivated these
extravagant investments
it all begins to crystallize when you
just zoom out sri lanka is
geographically blessed not only with
proximity to global shipping lanes it's
also just 34 miles at its closest point
to india one of china's closest rivals
coincidence maybe
but then in 2017 came what many see as
the smoking gun
unable to pay back its many
multi-million dollar loans sri lanka was
forced to hand over the port and 15 000
acres around it to china
it didn't take a wild imagination to see
how the country then already notorious
for making illegal claims in the south
china sea might use this strategic
outpost for more than mere shipping
since then close observers have watched
the same early warning signs play out
around the globe tajikistan djibouti
ethiopia kyrgyzstan angola nigeria what
could once be dismissed as
circumstantial many now argue has become
a neo-colonial playbook
it's called the debt trap debt trap
diplomacy debt truck debt trap diplomacy
here's what happens
first china approaches a small
impoverished nation usually in africa
with an offer it can't refuse
stadiums palaces roads ports it doesn't
really matter what it is
between 2000 and 2019 chinese banks have
loaned an estimated 153 billion dollars
to african governments alone
looking at a map it's hard to find a
place on the continent that hasn't taken
chinese loans
inevitably the project fails trains sit
empty airports open without flights
roads lead to nowhere and an oil
refinery runs at just six percent
capacity
in fact it almost seems like china wants
them to fail
finally the coup de grasse
after the fanfare has subsided and the
recipient country is left right back
where it started plus crumbling roads
and mountains of debt in swoops china
it generously offers to forgive the
loans and all it asks for is one thing
in return a tiny insignificant piece of
its sovereign territory
and voila china has a new military base
or rather that's how the story goes
the dead trap narrative is so often
repeated that it's been labeled a meme
yet almost everything said thus far is
either downright wrong or at least
misleading
in the case of sri lanka no debt was
ever forgiven no sovereignty was ceded
to china there is no military base and
china didn't approach sri lanka sri
lanka approached china
there's another way to make sense of
china's actions and it neither requires
that you assume it's evil nor benevolent
sponsored by brilliant learn math
science and computer science the
intuitive way with the link in the
description
when poor countries need money wealthy
ones through organizations like the
development assistance committee have
for the last 80 years provided it
but what these largely western countries
and banks will pay for has changed
dramatically over time
at one point 70 percent of world bank
financing went toward economic
infrastructure physical things like
roads water and electricity
today just 30 percent in favor of things
like education democratic elections and
family planning
but while the west has largely moved on
from infrastructure the developing world
hasn't
africa for instance receives only about
half of the 130 to 170 billion dollars
in infrastructure it needs each year
leaving it with a massive 68 to 108
billion dollar gap
now hold that thought for a second
sometime around 2010 the world's most
populous country had a problem
after two decades of breakneck growth
and development it began to put it
simply running out of things to build
china was still developing like crazy
but with diminishing returns
by 2012 the profit rate of new domestic
infrastructure projects fell below zero
meanwhile the entire economy and with it
the party's legitimacy depends on these
construction jobs excess foreign
exchange and the manufacturing industry
in short to feed the bottomless appetite
of capitalism china needed to find new
consumers
supply meet demand
in africa it found the perfect match
if one views development as a
predictable repeatable series of stages
china was only recently one stage ahead
of africa meaning it had lots of
experience building exactly the sorts of
things it's now needed
whether true or not china believed its
port cities and economic zones were
models that could be exported across the
globe
it was the perfect collision of excess
supply and unmet demand
in just a few short years chinese
overseas investment exploded
for recipient nations this wasn't just a
lot of money at the right time but also
the right kind
when giant multilateral institutions
like the world bank lend you money you
better be prepared to show exactly how
when who and where it went
and in addition to all the paperwork
you'll have to fill out and kickbacks
you'll miss out on you might even be
required to implement policy reforms
aid in other words is both free and
extremely costly
that is until china came along
the icing on the cake of chinese money
is that its companies don't ask why do
you need this project only when can we
get started
the result is that these investments are
designed to be as scrupulous and
economically viable as are the recipient
governments
when local politicians are careful and
institutions strong chinese investment
is uniquely valuable because it takes on
countries and projects someone more
cautious might avoid
the chinese shipping conglomerate costco
for instance turned greece's purest port
into the mediterranean's second largest
despite being one of only two bidders to
take control in 2016.
low-interest chinese loans helped angola
boost its credit rating giving it access
to new lenders
when it goes poorly on the other hand it
can go really poorly
the state-owned chinese communications
construction company was debarred from
the world bank for bribery and chinese
officials were involved in malaysia's
development berhad scandal
in the case of sri lanka's hambantota
port the story is a bit more complex
first you may ask was the project
destined to fail
the answer is inconclusive
what we do know is that its government
had been considering the project for
decades before it approached china
and while the port of colombo is indeed
nearby it was then approaching capacity
and many of the world's ports are close
to one another
a second and separate question is was
corruption involved
here the answer is a resounding yes
hambantota is not just any rural coastal
town but the hometown of the president
who signed off on the project
despite a large rock blocking the harbor
making it entirely unusable it opened on
his birthday in 2010 a sign of his
personal association and involvement
7.6 million dollars of project funds
were secretly diverted to his failed
re-election campaign
if there is a pattern to china's
overseas investments it might be
frequent though not universal corruption
bribes and kickbacks are widespread
across much of the developing world and
chinese companies seem generally willing
to pay them
a significant number of these projects
benefit no one except local politicians
and chinese developers
but corruption is not the same as a
deliberate debt trap
if china wanted its borrowers to default
on their loans one might expect it to
specifically target countries likely to
do so
yet independent researcher after
researcher has failed to find any such
evidence
quote it is unlikely that the belt and
road initiative will be plagued with
widespread debt sustainability problems
says the center for global developments
the loewy institute finds that quote 90
percent of china's bilateral loans have
gone to countries that could sustainably
absorb such debts
and finally debra brodigam of johns
hopkins writes quote so far in africa we
have not seen any examples where we
would say the chinese deliberately
entangled another country in debts
experts attribute china's slightly
higher lending to high-risk countries as
compared to say japan or the world bank
to its sheer scale
remember we're talking about over 10 000
projects across over 100 countries with
this much money being spread across this
wide surface area there will be a few
white elephants
add in it's no strings attached look the
other way approach and that number
doubles
now china may not set out with this
intention but you might argue that once
it sees an opportunity it takes
advantage
two countries are usually cited as
examples
first if all one knows about sri lanka
is that it took out a 300 million dollar
loan in 2008 from china who then took
over that same port in 2017 it may
appear to be a clear-cut case of debt
trap diplomacy
but what this version of events misses
is context
at the time the deal was struck china
was not even sri lanka's largest source
of debt actually it owed more to the
asian development bank japan and the
world bank the chinese portion
represented just 10 percent of the total
so why did sri lanka make the deal in
2004 it suffered a devastating tsunami
which contributed to a decline in
exports
this in turn led to a balance of trade
problem
in short because it was importing more
than it was exporting it ran out of u.s
dollars which it needed to make payments
on its loans
in other words sri lanka needed hard
cash today which china provided
it was almost certainly unwise to take
out even more loans to build the
hambantota port at least at that time
but it would have had this problem
regardless because the vast majority of
its debt was owed to other nations and
institutions
the exact details of the deal are also
frequently misconstrued
what actually happened is that the
chinese company paid 1.1 billion dollars
for a 70 stake of a 99-year lease
no debt was forgiven in the process
the money was used to pay off other
loans from other countries
neither will it gain a new military base
at least not as the lease stipulates
without sri lanka's explicit permission
next is djibouti
here in 2015 china built its first and
currently only overseas military base
but so has germany and spain and france
the uk saudi arabia and the u.s
its colonial history is long and
complicated but the ultra-condensed
version is that in place of natural
resources djibouti has access
access to this 18 mile wide choke point
between the red sea and indian ocean
its leaders have squeezed this fact for
all its worth by renting land to almost
any military willing to pay
even russia is invited
africa is not a country
every nation that borrows from china is
different
the dead trap narrative is right to
identify an inherent power differential
between giant china and the mostly much
smaller countries it lends to
but by portraying china as the only
party with agency it neglects the unique
circumstances of each nation and
absolves corrupt local politicians of
all culpability
take a look for instance at the amount
of debt china has refinanced
renegotiated or outright forgiven
less than france or japan but not far
behind the us or germany
this data suggests recipients have some
degree of leverage
of course none of this should be
confused with charity
when chairman xi jinping visits senegal
one of the continent's poorest nations
for example china gains something
valuable though intangible
while it may not be a primary motivation
it receives in return diplomatic
recognition support and when it comes to
say the south china sea or xinjiang
silence
so is chinese investment a an ambitious
21st century marshall plan on steroids
or b one giant trojan horse designed to
bankrupt poor countries and put the
people's liberation army in every corner
of the globe
well
neither
it's not much of a plan at all
you may have noticed this video makes no
reference to its official name the
belton road initiative
that's because it doesn't really exist
originally called the silk road economic
belt with central asian countries in
2013 the project has become increasingly
vague and amorphous since to this day
there is no clear definition of what is
and isn't a belt and road project in
fact different levels of its own
government disagree
look at a map of all participating
countries and it becomes so large as to
lose all meaning
there is no grand cohesive 50-year
strategy
and that's the problem
the same inefficient construction and
opaque backroom deals that characterize
the chinese domestic economy are now
being replicated abroad
that should raise eyebrows
the danger of criticizing china for the
wrong reasons is that it reduces
credibility when you need it the most
that's the importance of logical
consistency a skill that today's sponsor
brilliant teaches you in this brand new
fun interactive course
what i like about brilliant is that it
makes learning fun by focusing on
applying knowledge through interactive
puzzles riddles and games not just rote
memorizing facts
they have courses on everything from
programming to quantum computing physics
and calculus
click the link on screen now and the
first 200 people will get 20 off their
annual premium subscription
you can even gift a subscription to a
friend or family member
go pick what interests you most and
start learning today